so
it sounds like a ready for waymo like
machine learning is a huge part of the
stack
so it's a huge part of like not just
so obviously the the first the level
zero or whatever you said which is like
just object detection the things that
you know no that machine learning can do
but also starting to
to do prediction behavior and so on to
model the
what other or the other parties in the
scene entities in the scene are going to
do
so machine learning is more and more uh
playing a role in that
as well of course absolutely i think
we've been
going back to the you know earliest days
like you know darpa
even the grand challenge and team was
leveraging you know machine learning i
was like pre
you know image nut and that was very
different type of ml but uh and i think
actually that was before my time but the
stanford team
on during the grand challenge had a very
interesting machine learned
system that would you know use lighter
and camera
uh we've been driving in the desert and
it we had
built the model uh where it would kind
of
extend the range of free space reasoning
so we get a clear signal
from lighter and then it had a model
said hey like this stuff on camera kind
of sort of looks like this stuff and
lighter and i know this stuff and that
i've seen in lighter i'm very confident
there's free space
so let me extend that uh free space zone
into the camera range that would allow
the vehicle to drive faster right and
then we've been building on top of that
and kind of staying
and pushing the state of the art in a ml
in all kinds of different ml
uh over the years and in fact uh from
the earlier days i think you know 2010
is probably the year where google
uh maybe 2011 probably uh i got pretty
heavily involved
in machine learning uh kind of deep nuts
and at that time it's probably the only
company that was very heavily investing
in kind of state-of-the-art ml and
self-driving cars
right and they they they go you know
hand in hand
and we've been on that journey ever
since we're doing uh pushing
a lot of these areas uh in terms of
research you know at waymo and we
collaborate
very heavily with the researchers in
alphabet uh
and like all kinds of mel yeah supervise
the male unsupervised male
uh you know published some uh
interesting uh research papers in the
space uh
especially recently it's just this super
super active learning as well yeah so
super super active
uh of course there is you know kind of
like more uh mature stuff
like you know confidence for you know
object detection but there's some really
interesting really active uh
work that's happening in um kind of more
uh you know and and bigger models and
you know models
that uh have more structure uh to them
uh you know not just you know large uh
bitmaps and reasonable temporal
sequences
and some of the interesting
breakthroughs that you've you know we've
seen
in language models right you know
transformers you know
you know gpt 3 and friends uh
there's some really interesting
applications of some of the core
breakthroughs to those problems of you
know behavior prediction
as well as you know decision making and
planning right you can think about it
kind of the the behavior
uh how you know the path the
trajectories the the how people drive
and they have kind of a share a lot of
the fundamental structure
you know this problem there's you know
sequential
you know nature there's a lot of
structure uh in this representation
there is a strong locality kind of like
in sentences you know words that follow
each other they're strongly connected
but there's also kind of larger context
that doesn't have that locality and you
also see that in driving right what
is happening in the scene as a whole has
very strong implications on
uh you know the kind of the next step in
that sequence where
whether you're predicting what other
people are going to do whether you're
making your own decisions
or whether in the simulator you're
building generative models of
you know humans walking cyclists riding
other cars driving oh that's that's all
really fascinating like how
it's fascinating to think that uh
transformer models and all this
all the breakthroughs in language and
nlp that might be applicable
to like driving at the higher level at
the behavioral level that's kind of
fascinating
you